michel rocard bonsoir votre présence
dans cette émission de cartes sur table
et considérait déjà comme un événement
je rappelle que votre dernière grande
émission politique remonte à 13 mois
c'était naturellement un cartes sur
table depuis vous avez choisi la
discrétion pour ne pas dire le silence
c'est d'ailleurs une tactique a donné de
bons résultats qui vous est dans
l'ensemble favorables aujourd'hui vous
allez vous expliquer le moment est
important il ya une crise économique qui
touche la plupart des pays européens et
donc la france
la crise internationale s'aggrave toutes
les certitudes sont remises en cause
1981 c'est dans 15 mois et déjà les
candidats potentiels aux élections
présidentielles sont sur la ligne de
départ même s'ils ne veulent pas le
reconnaître lors avec alain duhamel
nous avons choisi de parler ce soir de
votre vision de la situation de
politique internationale de la société
telle que vous la proposer enfin des
problèmes politiques importants pour
lesquels nous garderons au cours cette
émission le temps qu'il faudra je veux
dire la crise de la gauche
le nouveau visage du parti communiste
les incertitudes
l'hésitation bref le malaise qui règne
peut-être au sein de votre parti parti
socialiste avec au coeur de tout cela
votre propre rôle genro car il ya une
crise économique mondiale grave il ya
une crise diplomatique mondiale grave ni
à une crise militaire mondiale assez
grave
est ce que vous vous sentiriez les
épaules d'un président de la république
capable de faire face à une question
ainsi posée
je ne crois pas qu'un homme convenable
puisse répondre oui mais ce que je crois
c'est qu'un homme qui se sent
représenter une force une espérance une
volonté collective peut sans doute
répondre euh oui c'est votre cas ce
n'est pas impossible qu'il a décidé tout
seul
non le parti socialiste a été sage
de décider que la désignation du
candidat qu'il proposerait un
rassemblement plus large et au suffrage
des français se ferait à l'automne
prochain
il n'est pas bon que la france souhaite
en campagne électorale permanente et
même si vous avez raison de souligner
que cette échéance de 1981 est très
importante elle est importante par la
situation même que vous avez rappelé
elle est importante par l'autorité que
la constitution de la vème république
donne à celui qui occupe les fonctions
de président de la république il n'en
est pas moins sage de réduire la durée
de la campagne au temps nécessaire et
pas plus les français s'en lasserait le
parti socialiste choisir on choisira
donc le candidat qu'ils proposent à
l'automne prochain je pense que c'est ça
je voudrais pas que dans les périodes de
crise et donc d'angoise la pente
naturelle c'est plutôt d'aller vers ceux
qui sont en fonction de ceux qui sont en
place ce qu'ils ont montré qu'ils
avaient fait leur preuve et donc on n'a
pas besoin de trouver cette aussi bien à
l'elysée que dans les partis politiques
et aux cétacés vrai historiquement dans
les débuts de crise et je suis sûr par
exemple que si l'on avait voté aux états
unis au tout début de la dernière grande
crise mondiale celle de 1929
monsieur ouvert l'incapable aurait été
reconduit mais quand un président en
exercice a montré à l'évidence au bout
de cinq six ou sept ans qu'il ne pouvait
rien à cette crise et qu'ils étaient
sans solution alors l'opinion
s'interroge et l'opinion a chance de
comprendre que c'est parfois le
changement qui fait la sécurité c'est
une image toute simple c'est l'image du
vélo pour ne pas tomber il faut
continuer à avancer pour se construire
un avenir
c'est ce que nous proposerons la france
c'est vrai seulement de valéry giscard
d'estaing c'est vrai aussi de françois
mitterrand que je sache françois
mitterrand pour notre
malheur à tous la gauche n'a pas occupé
les fonctions de président je viens de
citer le président en exercice monsieur
giscard d'estaing en effet exclusivement
il ferait un bon candidat à la
présidence monsieur françois mitterrand
mais il en est les titres et les talents
et le parti socialiste qui a la chance
d'avoir en ce moment deux candidats
possibles qui se respecte et s'estime
j'accorde à tout le travail qu'a fait
françois mitterrand qui a rassemblé les
socialistes et qui a tenté cet immense
effort et failli réussir de sortir le
parti communiste français de son ghetto
il souhaite revenir c'est son affaire
eh bien le respect elle estime que nous
nous portons font que tranquillisez vous
le choix du parti socialiste se fera de
toute façon sans drame nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs nous sommes tous les deux
très attachés à l'unité du parti et
c'est ce qui fait qu'il n'y aura pas de
primaires et qu'il y aura un accord de
consensus autour du parti du candidat le
plus capable de proposer d'animer au
tour du parti socialiste un très grasse
de rassemblement telle est la question
qui est posée au parti socialiste et les
largement politique plus encore que
personne quand vous dit tu n'iras pas de
primaires au sein du parti socialiste
pour désigner un candidat c'est un
pronostic un souhait ou la révélation
d'un accord françois mitterrand s'est
déjà les deux premiers éléments et
pourquoi pas un scoop du troisième vous
avez michel rocard 50 ans vous ne
manquez pas de d'expérience
d'intelligence de brio et la france est
aujourd'hui au milieu comme le monde
d'un tourbillon d'une tempête
internationale et vous n'avez jamais
exercé de responsabilités importantes au
niveau de l'état ce que ça vous fait pas
peur
non dans la mesure où je sais que les
forces qui veulent le changement social
dans ce pays ne sont pas irréfléchie que
le message qu'elle porte est un message
responsable et puis vous savez
l'opposition n'est pas sans
responsabilité
la vie politique est difficile aussi le
fait d'y garder tête froide sens de
l'état garder le sens de l'état est
peut-être plus encore difficile dans
l'opposition que ce ne l'est au pouvoir
selon de ces facteurs qui rassure et
d'autre part si la politique de la
france avait été ces dernières semaines
en matière internationale plus assurée
moisir résolu
vous auriez peut-être raison mais je
crois précisément que les résolutions
dont monsieur giscard d'estaing a donné
le signe au cours de ces dernières
semaines
la france est restée silencieuse pendant
les quatre ou cinq premiers jours qui
ont suivi kaboul s'était tout de même
étrange et voilà qu ensuite le monde
internationale s'interroge sur deux
communiqués successifs
l'un signé avec le chancelier
d'allemagne fédérale et qui rappelle que
la france est fidèle à l'alliance
atlantique et l'autre signe avec le
premier ministre d'inde qui sort de
l'inde madame gandhi qui s'en vient
rappeler deux thèmes c'est une
déclaration presque non alignés au à la
lecture je les amenais les est là tous
les deux ne sont pas absolument
contradictoires mais leur tonalité
différente et personne ne sait ce qu'est
la politique de la france
cela est dangereux cela est mauvais et
je crois moi que les forces de gauche un
candidat socialiste serait plus capable
d'assurer une continuité et une très
grande fermeté
il n'ya pas qu'on pouvoir ou connaît les
tempêtes et près tout le sous marin en
somme avant qu'on ne revienne à la
politique internationale vous ne vous
sentez pas fragile et vous vous sentez
prêt en cas vous êtes journaliste
professionnel vous connaissez bien mais
biographie ici j'étais fragile le moins
du monde je serai déjà politiquement
décédé n'est-il pas vrai
est prêt l'avenir le dira je n'aurais
pas l'outrecuidance d'être ici devant
vous si je ne me sentais pas monsieur
rocard nous on parle effectivement de la
politique internationale quand on voit
ce qui est en train de se passer à
kaboul ce qui s'annonce aux pâquis sens
qui a lieu dans l'océan indien la
difficulté des rapports entre l'est et
l'ouest
est ce que vous vous croyez un danger
d'hyères je crois en effet aux dangers
de tensions locales croissante et
pouvant provoquer des conflits en effet
locaux quand on parle de guerre et qu'on
est en france
la chose est plus grave car elle
sous-entend la guerre nucléaire
l'holocauste la fin de la planète la fin
de l'espèce humaine et j'en veux
beaucoup à monsieur le président de la
république dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions et au soir de la nouvelle
année d'avoir l'occasion des voeux
évoqué le problème de la guerre
s'agissant de la france alors que nous
sommes d'une part un pays relativement
calme et d'autre part un pays protégés
par l'armement nucléaire mondiale par
l'armement nucléaire stratégique genre
qu'est ce que vous auriez préféré qu'il
dise ça va bien chez nous ça va mal chez
les hommes n'auront peut-être la guerre
mais nous serons à l'écart non pas du
tout il est clair que l'univers est en
difficulté mais il l'est dans des zones
qui ne sont pas couvertes par les
accords de yalta est garantie par cet
équilibre terrible mais pour être
terrible il n'en est pas moins un
équilibre et le monde change d'une autre
manière et plutôt temps dehors de
l'europe
si vous le voulez bien je souhaiterais
que nous prenions une deux ou trois
minutes pour réfléchir à cet état du
monde et comprendre ce qui se passe
avant de passer aux propositions et à la
réponse c'est l'union soviétique que
vient aujourd'hui une inquiétude liée à
la dernière manifestation de sa
politique et l'invasion de l'afghanistan
et avant de juger quitte à juger
sévèrement d'ailleurs et vous le verrez
il faut comprendre les responsables et
dirigeants de l'union soviétique sont
persuadés de construire un monde
j'ai encore dans la tête un toast de
monsieur souslov jets ont été reçus en
délégation avec quelques phrases dont
une était nous nous sentons responsables
de la paix du monde pour deux c'était
pendant watergate
je n'aimais pas je n'approuvais pas mais
telle est leur sentiment construire ce
monde est difficile ils ont fait un
choix d'administration économique qui ne
fonctionne pas la planification
bureaucratique n'a jamais marché nulle
part et nous le savons nous socialistes
démocratiques d'occident parce que
vivant dans un pays où l'économie
fonctionne autrement injuste d'ailleurs
mais pour des raisons que nous
connaissons bien les dirigeants
soviétiques sont hors d'état d'accepter
cette analyse qui met en cause toute la
structure de leur pays du coup que
pense-t-il il pense simplement que s'ils
ont des difficultés internes à nourrir
leur population sait que leur pays est
jeune c'est que leurs cadres sont
inexpérimentés
d'où découlent ses conséquences qui leur
faut du temps j'ai entendu par un
dirigeant de haute importance cité la
durée d'un demi-siècle d'un demi siècle
lés dirigeants soviétiques se disent il
nous faut ce temps sans guerre d'où la
protection de la forteresse la
protection du glacis et autant je
condamne fermement et je pense qu'il
fallait condamner tout de suite
l'invasion de l'afghanistan autant il
faut comprendre dans quel contexte cela
se situe c'est toujours la protection du
glacis l'union soviétique
mais il ya plus et c'est là que le monde
bouge rassurer mais il faut bien
comprendre c'est là que le monde bouge
les soviétiques ont très bien compris
aussi que le modèle de développement la
manière dont nous aidons les pays du
tiers-monde ne marche pas ils ne sortent
pas de la grande misère et du cou ou
bien certains ne décolle pas l'inde le
bangladesh la moitié de l'afrique et
ceux qui décollent à notre manière
capitaliste le font dans des conditions
d'inégalités sociales d'oppression
social croît sort avec des tensions qui
généralement se traduisent en dictature
c'est l'essentiel de l'amérique latine
et c'est maintenant presque la moitié de
l'afrique
quelques pays essaient de se protéger
tout cela ça a été le cas de cuba au
début c'est le cas de l'algérie
aujourd'hui de la tanzanie du pays eût
du pérou un autre moment
aujourd'hui le mozambique et l'angola
sont dans cette situation nous ne savons
pas aider les pays du tiers-monde qui
cherche à faire un développement non
capitaliste
du coup ils n'ont plus comme fournisseur
de garanties diplomatiques
vendeurs d'armes les frontières de la
colonisation tout était fragile que
l'union soviétique et l'armement
fantastique de l'union soviétique est là
pour dire une fois que ces pays sont
entrés dans notre orbite
n'y touchez pas je dis pour ma part une
politique de paix consiste à contrer
battre cette situation elle ne consiste
pas à s'imaginer que la guerre menace la
houle équilibre nucléaire est installé
elle consiste à être capable de lancer
une politique de détente une politique
des droits de l'homme et une politique
des dockers mende qui permettent un
développement sans profit voilà ce que
serait une grande ambition nationale
pour la france excusez moi c'était un
tout petit peu long c'est en même temps
très caricatural mais là est un axe et
j'aurais préféré celui là où fait de
jouer sur les nerfs des français en
parlant guerre ou un pays qui n'est pas
ni menacer ni directement concernés sans
décrire ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
aider la zone où l'on a faim
la zone où les explosions peuvent venir
à se développer en somme malgré kaboul
vous fait confiance à la sagesse de
l'union soviétique
je crois que l'union soviétique qui nous
concerne je crois que l'union soviétique
n'est pas dirigé par des irresponsables
mais l'union soviétique et une vision du
monde radicalement incompatibles avec la
nôtre et je n'aime pas l'expression
faire confiance à l'union soviétique
mais je fais confiance pour maintenir la
paix à tous ceux qui seront maintenir l'
équilibre dans sa stabilité
elle pas expansionniste dans ce moment
elle est expansionniste dans la mesure
où il n'y a pas de réponse ferme
en face et cette réponse peut-être de
consolidation d'un équilibre et en même
temps d'organisation du développement
donc donc la france n'a pas eu tort de
garder le contact avec l'union
soviétique alors que d'autres puissances
l'inciter à faire le contraire
on peut très bien être ferme en gardant
le contact
je suis même persuadé qu'une hésitation
cunill résolution aussi évidente que
celle à laquelle nous avons assisté sont
plutôt de nature à convaincre les
socialistes les soviétiques de notre
faiblesse
et je ne crois pas que ce soit bon y
compris pour l'équilibré et pour la paix
sont des veaux du général de gaulle qui
quelques mois après avoir retiré les
armées françaises du commandement
intégré atlantique de l'otan'' venant
en présence de la crise de cuba a été le
premier chef d'état d'occident affirmé
sa solidarité avec les états unis devant
la grande tension
autrement dit quand la tension atteint
un niveau tel que c'est entre les deux
super prescience que cela se joue
l'équilibré ne peut être préservée que
si chacun sait où il est et s'il n'y a
pas de doute mais indépendamment de
cette situation chaque pays a son rôle
et la france on aurait à tout
particulier alors accomplir les tâches
de son ressort ce2 notamment par rapport
aux tyrans justement concrètement quels
sont les répliques les réponses que vous
auriez souhaité pour la france devant
les initiatives soviétique concrètes une
fermeté immédiate qui condamne
désapprouve et ne laisse aucune espèce
d'ambiguïté sur le fait que ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan et pour la france
inacceptable fermeté verbal verbal
d'abord et en personne ne savait rien
dans le deuxième est interdite ensuite
je n'aime pas la politique spectacle et
la politique symbolique il est possible
dans tout l'ensemble des relations du
monde occidental avant lui avec le monde
soviétique de faire l'examen de ce que
doit être mise en question par les voilà
bon alors c'est ça concrètement il ya
des sensibilités de sanction il peut y
voir les jeux olympiques qui peut y
avoir des sanctions économiques
et puis voir des sanctions militaires
prévoient des sanctions politiques alors
créé l'effet de votre choix
je vous en prie ne posons pas les
questions comme ça il s'agit d'abord de
garder ses nerfs froid et je ne suis pas
sûr que la référence aux sanctions sur
la seule issue possible
ceux qui étaient en question s'était
d'abord que l'union sovétique sache que
ces propos inacceptables et à la limite
c'est peut-être une au niveau de notre
propre dispositif diplomatique et
militaire que des formes de
réorganisation de présence par rapport à
nos voies de communication pétrolière
ils sont immédiatement proche de cette
zone
bref une présentation d'une france
ferment et qui sait ce qu'elle veut
pour le reste je maintiens
l'intelligence je voudrais s'il vous
plaît maintenir l'analyse de tout à
l'heure et rappeler qu en effet l'union
soviétique a hélas des raisons de
considérer nous les désapprouvons mais
dans sa mentalité à elle puisque
nous voulons éviter la guerre préserver
aussi il appelle donc la détente
nous devons la comprendre l'union
soviétique avait signé un traité avec
l'afghanistan dès 1931
c'est même dès 1922 que lénine a reçu un
premier premier ministre étranger qui
était le premier ministre d'afghanistan
l'union soviétique a des raisons de
penser de considérer que l'afghanistan
fait partie de son glacis et de croire
que les occidentaux s'ils étaient
résignés je plaide pour ma part que ce
que doit être clair c'est que les
peuples des droits de l'homme je n'aime
pas les appeler occidentaux c'est une
assimilation à système économique que
par ailleurs nous voulons changer mais
il est vrai qu'il y à une partie du
monde qui est solidement ancré dans la
volonté de défendre une conception des
droits de l'homme plein d'autres nous
sommes là et cela nous n'en démordront
pas nous n'accepterons pas on ne doit
pas accepter que d'autres pays du
tiers-monde bascule de la même manière
et là était sans doute la riposte la
plus nécessaire à préparer face à la
politique afghane de l'union soviétique
c'est cela que j'aurais aimé entendre
dans le message de la france et c'est
cela que j'aurais aimé lire dans le
communiqué signé avec madame bandits qui
d'ailleurs l'aurait sans doute forcé
d'accepter une augmentation de la
tension internationale si on sentait que
la crise monte donc dans un moment grave
parce qu'il faut marquer son camp et de
quelle façon pour michel rocard
mon sentiment est le suivant lorsque la
tension monte à un niveau qui met en
cause les deux superpuissances
c'est en effet l' équilibre qu'il
convient de préserver et il faut que
l'on sache où est la france nous ne
sommes pas un pays neutre donc un peu
vous dire que ce l'heure où est leur âge
où elle serait dans ce cas elle sa
signature figure au bas du traité
d'alliance atlantique et personne et pas
même nous les hommes de gauche n'était
même pas dans le programme commun nous
demandent le retrait de cette signature
de la france les choses sont claires il
est des moments où ils doivent être
réaffirmé mais au delà de notre
situation en occident si j'ose dire la
france est aussi en europe
il se trouve que la garantie nucléaire
américaine est donné à l'europe mais à
un niveau qui ne couvre pas tous les
problèmes
l'europe est pauvre en énergie les
américains ne le sont pas nous voies de
communication et
nouvelle communication pétrolières sont
fragiles de plus l'europe est flanqué à
lorient d'une yougoslavie qui va
connaître un destin incertain
lorsque la succession s'ouvrira de
l'autriche qui est un pays neutre et de
l'allemagne qui reste divisé
c'est un jeu de pressions diplomatiques
appuyé sur des systèmes militaires
derrière devant lesquelles la garantie
américaine ne joue pas là est nécessaire
une politique adaptée et cette politique
doit être capable de répondre en termes
de pression d'équivalent d'intensité
toujours avec l'idée de bien mesurer les
réflexes nous voulons préserver la paix
mais nous ne pouvons pas faire confiance
pour le faire est la seule bienveillance
soviétique devant une horde des armées
c'est bien clair je pense est favorable
au développement de la force de frappe
française
oui cela éclaire les résultats
quelquefois par exemple écouter la force
de frappe française actuellement a
atteint un niveau suffisamment dissuasif
par rapport à l'union soviétique
ce n'est pas il faut qu'elle reste
techniquement en état
souvenez-vous de l'utilisation de ce
terme au moment même enfin dans ces
dernières années en cours de toutes les
réflexions et il se trouve que la
situation qu'elle je viens d'évoquer les
garanties à donner à notre nous
communication pétrolière d'une part et
le moyen de maintenir une pression
adaptée à celle que lors de la frange
est peu suffit d peut subir sa vie
autriche neutre allemagne est divisée
n'appelle pas un dispositif nucléaire
mais peut-être une redistribution notre
dispositif militaire conventionnelle et
tactique mais cela est travail d'expert
une fois les missions définies une force
d'intervention probablement développé
développé par rapport à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui je le pense profondément
nous avons été très nombreux à dire
qu'on avait à l'électro sacrifier
armements nucléaires français et que
nous étions sur le plan conventionnel un
pays relativement découvert or le type
de pression qui se font aujourd'hui crée
ici une insécurité par rapport aux états
qui sont les états qui défendent les
droits de l'homme j'en parlais tout à
l'heure
comment vous jugez vous appréciez la
nature du régime soviétique est ce que
vous dites que c'est un régime qui ne
respecte pas les droits de l'homme
effets d'un régime totalitaire
comment vous le juger comme un régime
qui ne respecte pas les droits de
l'homme en effet et comme un régime
totalitaire c'est clair
mais il y a le totalitarisme cynique
dont l'assassinât est un moyen de
travail habituel et justifier la
différence et nous n'y a ce n'est pas ce
que je veux dire
nous avons nous portons l'un et l'autre
ne jouons pas au petit jeu des petites
phrases nous portons sur le goulag je
pense le même sentiment
simplement il est vrai que l'union
soviétique est née d'un grand projet
pour l'homme d'un grand projet de
libération humaine et c'est un des plus
sinistres malheur de l'histoire le fait
de l'avoir vu ainsi transformé mais ne
faisons pas discrédit ou peuple
soviétique ou peuple ou plurielle
rassemblés dans l'union soviétique de ce
qu'ils peuvent porter comme espérance
pour l'avenir du grand message il vient
leurs dissidents parmi les hommes les
plus cultivés du monde d'aujourd'hui et
dont le message précisément sur des
droits de l'homme et d'une force d'une
intensité fantastique mais en même temps
il est né en russie soviétique une autre
façon d'être
250 millions d'habitants y vivent et
nous voulons la paix avec eux je ne
crois pas que nous préserverons la paix
sans nous connaître sans voyager sans
nous rencontrer la politique de paix
c'est donc à la fois la fermeté puisque
nous ne pouvons malheureusement pas
l'éviter mais en même temps dans cette
fermeté le maintien des capacités de
rencontre de dialogue et d'échangé qui
doivent nous habituer les uns aux autres
et à vivre ensemble sur cette planète
quoi vivent dans des systèmes sociaux
forts différents que nous on a la france
maintenant mature aux carmes pour vous
je leur ai aimé avoir le temps de parler
de l'europe sans verrou des boucholeurs
pour vous en 1981 où sont les chances de
l'économie française les chances de
l'économie française elles sont
multiples mais si je devais donner un
mot qui exprime en plus courts
ce qu'il nous faut faire pour valoriser
ses chances ce serait celui de
planification souple
pourquoi nous ne préparons pas notre
avenir se payer est riche d'un certain
nombre ressources pas tellement
d'ailleurs essentiellement agricole du
point de vue des richesses qui sont chez
nous dans notre sol et notre sous sol
n'est pas merveilleusement riche mais il
est riche aussi beaucoup de cultures de
beaucoup de savoir accumulé de beaucoup
de recherches scientifiques stocker et
et en potentiel or nous sommes
incapables de prévoir notre avenir à
long terme
qu'il s'agisse du marché de la viande on
a fait les halles de rungis à paris et
la ville est plutôt la viande l'huile
est au moment même où on organisait des
marchés sur les lieux de la production
qu'il s'agisse du transport on a fait
qu'on porte du lieu de s'occuper de
moyens de transport à plus grande
capacité et répondre au mieux à un état
des techniques et ainsi de suite
et tout ça sont des décisions qu'on n'a
pas confrontés les unes aux autres
il y a huit ans qu'on attend un schéma
directeur des voies navigables pour la
france il ne sort pas on n'est pas
capable de se mettre d'accord
bref on pourrait citer des exemples dans
tous les sens des exemples de décision
qui se contredisent ou de chance
française non explorées il en est dans
tous les sens par exemple notre forêt
une chance mon explorer nous importe
nous exportons du bois brut et nous
importons du meuble et toutes les formes
de bois travaillés par exemple toutes
les chances agroalimentaire que nous
pouvons avoir par exemple aussi dans le
domaine de l'informatique combien de
temps at il fallu poursuivre une ligne
je vous rappelle notre histoire
informatique depuis 20 ans cinq ou six
décisions brisant la précédente chaque
quatre ou cinq ans maintenant enfin il
semble que l'on souffle un peu et qu' il
soit sorti quelque chose de la cedh ausy
mais après qu'elle rattrapage la
construction aéronautique a connu aussi
tout
bien des difficultés maintenant c'est
dans le champ de la chimie lourde c'est
dans jean de la la bio alimentation que
l'on peut s'engager dans ce sens qu'il
ya des atouts iliad est à tes efforts
tardifs mais les efforts et ça irait
mieux avec une planification souple
je crois nécessaire que nous nous
mettions d'accord sur les décisions
importantes et sur leurs rapports avec
les infrastructures du pays
mais plus que cela le problème français
aujourd'hui me semble être davantage
celui de la bonne entente des français
entre eux celui y compris dans la marche
même des entreprises de la capacité de
notre pays de négocier avec lui même de
trancher les problèmes ou en minimisant
les conflits et d'abord les problèmes de
salaires et les problèmes d'autorité de
pouvoir dans l'entreprise
nous croyons très nécessaire une forte
décentralisation du pays
je prendrai un exemple immédiat le
chômage et prom est aujourd'hui le drame
français le plus grave européen il est
heureux européens mais avec nous nous
battons presqu'un record en europe nous
sommes à 6 % notre population active en
chômage
l'allemagne est à 5 la grande bretagne
zinc et demi ou quelque chose de ce
genre maintenant nous battons je sais
bien que les générations qui arrivent
sur le marché du travail sont plus
nombreuses en france qu'ailleurs mais
tout de même on ne peut pas dire qu'on
s'en est occupé il y aurait quantité de
choses à faire dans ce domaine notamment
celle ci c'est dans la zone des petites
et moyennes entreprises que la crise
économique a été la plus dure c'est
année dernière en france il naît chaque
année beaucoup moins d'entreprises qu'il
n'en meurt il faut le savoir
or l'état tel qu'il est organisé
administrés ne s'est pas à s'occuper
d'entreprises de moins de 2000
travailleurs ya que les grosses unités
qui compte pour lui je le vois en tant
que maire il nous faut des autorités
régionales responsable des
infrastructures capables de gérer les
politiques d'environnement les
politiques fiscales aussi les politiques
dead au niveau de petites unités de
production qui sont notre principale
chance pour l'avenir mais on ne peut pas
le faire depuis une administration aussi
centralisé que l'actuel une puissante
réforme régionale et une réforme qui
donne à nos communes le droit en flat
possibilité de s'occuper de ses
problèmes sur lesquels bien souvent les
mères et leurs élus savent ce qui se
passe connaît ses besoins seraient
capables de répondre et non pas le droit
j'ai fait une zone industrielle dans ma
commune le préfet de région m'a dit
monsieur le maire vous avez violé la loi
j'en suis convenu j'ai créer 80 emplois
j'en étais fier cette décentralisation
elle est possible en temps de crise mais
contraire elle mes doigts mais
parfaitement la société à laquelle nous
voulons que nous voulons édifier à la
construction de laquelle nous avons
participé je l'appellerai volontiers le
socialisme de la responsabilité et je
suis sûr que des diffusions plus grande
de responsabilité on obtiendrait des
français c'est juste un effort beaucoup
plus précis par le très puissant a
justement hier dimanche président la
république a relancé le thème de la
participation j'ai entendu cela il se
trouve que ce thème correspond aussi à
certaines aspirations que c'est quand
même par exemple la cfdt à travers n'ont
pas la même façon mais à travers le
problème d'expression sur les lieux du
travail
est ce qu'il ya des points communs dans
les recherches ou pas pour vous répondre
sur le point de savoir s'il ya des
points communs dans les recherches
encore faudrait-il savoir s'il y a
simplement recherche le mot de
participations - il me rappelle un grand
discours du général de gaulle en 10 947
et depuis nous l'avons vu resurgir à
chaque campagne électorale
il s'agit là au fond essentiellement de
participation électorale
mais curieusement il se passe rien entre
deux combats entre les campagnes une
fois les résultats attendus la cession
par le milieu de semaine écoutez je vous
en prie le candidat giscard d'estaing en
1973 et toi sous le son de 14 avait
beaucoup promis c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs qu'on peut faire le compte il
est accablant sur ce plan là il avait
moins avancés le mot de participation
ses rapports avec la filiation gaulliste
n'était pas encore tout à fait clair si
il n'était pas en position tout capté
grâce à leurs gardes ce sont leurs
affaires de famille ce que je veux dire
moi c'est qu'il avait préféré monnayer
la chose dans le détail et que
précisément sur le point que nous venons
de parler il avait annoncé son intention
de mettre en place des autorités
régionales
élus responsables dotés devrait pouvoir
il n'a pas fallu un an et demi après son
élection pour qu'il abandonne totalement
cette idée et la répudie haut dans un
discours dijon je crois bien voilà un
des plus flagrants exemples
c'est tout de même dommageable alors si
vous permettez
je vais continuer à m'amuser je ne peux
plus prendre le candidat qui avait aussi
annoncé dans sa campagne incidemment que
l'on mensualisées ou le paiement des
retraites ne faisons que pour les
fonctionnaires pour le moment très au
sérieux et restons sur ce qu'il a dit si
vous permettez l'orateur s'est bien
intéressante 3% du capital
donner aux travailleurs je suis persuadé
mois que hier le président a eu droit à
un immense éclat de rire dans toutes les
familles de travailleurs ou de
responsables syndicaux qui savent à peu
près de 2 quoi il retourne
quel est le problème des travailleurs il
est double premier non la sécurité de
leur emploi et de leurs revenus
et deuxièmement leur dignité dans
l'entreprise c'est à dire leurs
responsabilités d'homme et de femme
créateurs dans l'entreprise 3%
c'est-à-dire un revenus aléatoires
résultat c'est l'essentiel
malheureusement c'est ce sur quoi la
presse a titré je la prends très au
sérieux moi la presse soit que ces
liaisons vous n'est ce pas alors je
prends ce sur quoi la presse a mis
l'accent fait essayer vous avez d'autres
éléments comme moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était une plaisanterie que c'était se
moquer du monde du travail les
travailleurs attendent des
responsabilités qui ne soit pas lié à
leur faible capital et un revenu qui
soit de la sécurité si vous voulez ça
m'a fait un peu penser à
marie-antoinette rejoint la fermière
alors vous nous parliez des vous nous
parliez des promesses du candidat valéry
giscard d'estaing sur des promesses du
candidat michel rocard vous avez
toujours été une autre et que je prends
mes peu attendez attendez je vais le
temps
c'est vrai vous aime vous avez toujours
été favorable à l'idée d'autogestion
depuis longtemps tout à fait ce que si
vous étiez candidat à la présidence de
république vous feriez campagne
notamment sur le thème de l'autogestion
autrement dit concrètement est-ce que
l'autogestion c'est quelque chose de
possible en france au milieu de la crise
économique mondiale et avec des états
européens suivant une politique opposé
l'autogestion d'abord ce n'est pas un
modèle tout fait qu'on aurait dans la
tête pour le plaquer d'un seul coup avec
des quantités de projet de loi qu'on
ferait voter instantanément
l'autogestion c'est une marche en avant
c'est une dynamique longue longue très
long c'est ce que les techniciens
appellent d'un mot affreux mais précis
un processus ça veut dire au fond que
chaque fois qu'une décision est à
prendre on cherchera à ce que ce qu'ils
apprennent soit situé le plus près
possible de ce qu'ils appliqueront de
ceux qui la subiront quel que soit le
système social sarr il se trouve que
partir dans ce sens revient à modifier
le système cette prothèse sociale
prenez le cas de l'entreprise d'une
immense entreprise d'un groupe
multinational
si on décide de décentraliser beaucoup
les décisions et de les placer sous le
contrôle de ceux qui vont les subir
ça veut dire que le conseil
d'administration capitaliste en sera
largement dépourvu donc ça contribue
aussi à changer le système social je
voudrais encore dit rien il se trouve
que ce mode auto gestion est un mot
presque technique
je préfère décrire la société qui à la
construction de laquelle nous voulons
travailler sous le mot de socialisme de
la responsabilité ou socialiste de la
liberté et je vais venir
c'est pas que ça fait moins peur mais la
santé du président tito est gravement
menacée si séjour doivent connaître une
fin ces temps ci nous passerons du temps
à réfléchir à cette immense et
courageuse et expériences de ce petit
peuple que la yougoslavie
laissons lui le bénéfice d'être seul à
décrire ce qu'il a inventé chez lui qui
est lui est propre et qui n'est pas un
modèle qui est une expérience historique
sur laquelle livre qu'il faudrait
étudier
nous nous dirons des enseignements mais
que nous ne pouvons pas prendre comme
modèle c'est un autre niveau de
développement c'est un pays très agraire
largement qui était encore analphabète
quand il a commencé alors
qui d autogestion dire au contraire
quand compétence collective de tout le
monde parlons du socialisme de la
liberté parlons du socialiste de la
responsabilité
parlons du socialisme à visage humain ça
veut dire la même chose et ce sera mieux
comprendre en quoi ces différentes
socialiste de la liberté du libéralisme
social en ce fait que le libéralisme
social n'a jamais cherché à mettre en
cause le pouvoir économique et son
organisation tout bonnement
radicalisation les travailleurs qui
auraient voté pour éventuellement le
candidat de gauche se contenterait d'un
processus long long long avant de voir
arriver la transformation de la france
pourquoi voulez vous que les
travailleurs ne soient pas capables eux
mêmes de se rendre compte que la gestion
de leur entreprise n'est pas facile
beaucoup d'entre eux savent et disent
que les responsabilités il faut aussi
les apprentis initié en mai 68 même bien
des travailleurs le disait et le
découvrait avec force
de plus n'oubliez pas qu'une
redistribution différente des pouvoirs
aussi bien dans nos collectivités
territoriales régions et communes et
départements qu'à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise s'accompagnera aussi d'un
changement dans la répartition du revenu
national la lutte de la gauche est
depuis toujours lutte contre les
inégalités
ça n'est pas venu dans la conversation
ça fait tout de même partie de
l'essentiel de notre projet la france
bat le record de la justice sociale dans
les pays développés d'europe du centre
et du nord
j'ai le regard est ce que
l'expérimentation sociale l'innovation
et découverte ça n'est pas un peu au
dessus de nos moyens dans une période
aussi difficile et à un moment où nos
partenaires applique des politiques qui
tourne le dos à ses solutions au fond
est-ce qu'on peut être les seuls à faire
en période de crise de l'expérimentation
sociale
ce n'est pas que de l'expérimentation
sociale quand c'est pour est rassurant
du lycée st je dis tout net que si la
france se donne deux puissantes régions
dont les autorités soit élu au suffrage
universel direct et qu'elle soit
responsable
on n'en sera pas à l'expérimentation
sociale on fera de la grande politique
avec en effet la découverte la première
année les deux premières années les
nouveaux élus n'auront pas une complète
connaissance une complète
expérimentation de leurs responsabilités
c'est un risque à prendre et non les
oreillettes vous ferme et audi dans les
entreprises
je crois
profondément premièrement dans le
secteur public la loi le règlement
doivent permettre une plus grande
diffusion des responsabilités il ya très
longtemps que l'ensemble des forces
politiques et syndicales de gauche le
demande dans le secteur privé
je crois que cette évolution doit se
faire de plus en plus par la voix de
l'accord négocié de l'acompte de la
lutte de la grève parfois et de la
convention c'est un grand mouvement de
la lutte ouvrière de ces dix dernières
années que plus cela va et plus les
revendications comportent des volontés
de pouvoir de peser sur les décisions de
l'entreprise et pas seulement des
exigences de rémunération est d'ailleurs
en ce moment même la combativité des
travailleurs de france est bien plus
forte qu'il ya un an
les conflits sont locaux limité à
l'entreprise il déborde peu la
solidarité a perdu un peu son sens
politique à cause de l'état de désunion
politique de la gauche mais il ya une
grande combativité syndicales
aujourd'hui entreprise par entreprise et
qui est porteuse de toutes ces
revendications votre éditeur justement
si elle reste de l'entreprise c'est
parce que dans l'entreprise elle est
unitaire et le reste unitaire à
condition que le titre est dans les
problèmes localisés dans l'entreprise ça
se passe bien entre la cgt la cfdt par
exemple mais il ya beaucoup de conflits
sur lesquels se passe pas si mal en
effet des quantités c'est au niveau
national que les effets des décisions du
parti communiste français sur lyon la
gauche ont leurs conséquences jusque
dans le monde syndical et les décisions
internationales
aussi c'est après tout un dirigeant
syndical qui disait que l'ombre de
kaboul plane sur le mouvement ouvrier
français c'est bien normal également
vous disiez tout à l'heure michel rocard
que un éventuel candidat devait être
prudent et d'une certaine façon modeste
est-ce qu'en 1981 le programme était
nationalisation de la gauche est actuel
où est ce qu'il est par caïques
comment vous le jugez plus beau but de
tester port
je pense qu'il est actuel je reviens
d'autriche et l'honneur ya trois jours
déjeuner avec le chancelier d'autriche
et j'ai vu d'ailleurs un homme assez
sera dont l'inquiétude sur la situation
internationale est plus modérée que la
nôtre et cela est un message qui mérite
d'être d'une autriche n'est pas la
france d'où l'on triche n'est pas la
france est bien intéressant l'autriche
-2 5% d'inflation lent moins de 3% de la
population active en chômage et 35% de
la production faite par un immense
secteur public
ça marche très bien l'autriche
permettez-moi une anecdote aussi l'autre
dimanche c'était retour de vacances pour
les enfants
je suis allé chercher les biens à la
gare les trains venaient de pau il y en
avait deux qui arrivait à 14h16 et 14h19
nous étions 350 400 par an sur le bord
de ce qu'est en train d'attendre le
train 14h16 annonce du premier
14h13 la motrice mené kilomètres de
quais épicé neyrial mans à deux ou trois
leur histoire d'arriver à l'heure cet
immense tarifs doucement et à 14h16 coup
de frein arrêt je passe vers le second
train mes enfants atteints dans le
second 14h19
même chose à la minute où je me suis dit
comme ça que ça marche pas mal le
secteur public vous savez et je me suis
dit aussi que sur ses 350 personnes 400
qui étaient autour de moi peut-être la
moitié votre honte à droite en criant
bien des choses sur les nationalisations
en ne se souvenant pas qu'aucun d'entre
eux n'avait la moindre crainte sur la
sécurité de leurs enfants dans le train
ni sur le fait qu'il arriverait à l'air
nous avons des choses à faire dans ce
pays qu'ils appellent une meilleure
gestion
quels sont les drames français sur le
plan et non vous est posée sur les
nationalisations de grandes questions je
continue si vous permettez c'est la
sidérurgie c'est le provost le groupe
boussac
je parle des grandes faillites je parle
des grands drames de mauvaise gestion ce
philippe reines tout ça c'est le briser
quels sont les secteurs où des
dirigeants incapables ne peuvent pas
être remplacés ou le patronat de droit
divin s'effondre quand il n'est pas
capable et où personne ne peut rien dire
nous en avons plein l'économie française
tout le textile naturel qui n'a pas su
faire sa reconversion
je n'ai jamais été un partisan
outrancier des nationalisations
je suis de ceux qui savent qu'elles sont
difficiles
affaire qui n'en faut pas trop qu'il est
stupide de tout nationaliser et que
c'est le moment j'ai ouvert dans la
gauche et une grande controverse sur la
manière de les faire bien plus encore
que sur le principe
discret c'est sur l'allemagne voire
internationaux the pour le nepad être
discret discret il est il est de mettre
leurs structures publiques dans des
conditions de fonctionnement qui ne soit
pas celle du tube d'une [ __ ] elle
tatillonne et quotidienne des directions
du ministère des finances dont le métier
n'est pas en effet de produire mais ce
serait le moment si vous étiez élu je
pense pour les secteurs les plus urgents
tenez je vais prendre un exemple qui
n'est pas dans la liste du programme
commun c'est l'eau potable
il ya un grave problème de l'eau potable
que les français connaissent mal parce
que nous risquons de manquer de cette
ressource
il ya d'autre part dans sa distribution
et dans l'organisation de notre pays de
très grandes faiblesses des
discontinuités et puis des concussion
les des prix excessifs
on paye l'habitant du sol de france paye
son no 2 1 à 20 selon les endroits les
communes et c'est tout ce système est
dans un état profondément mauvais et
appelle une grande réorganisation il
faudrait réussir là ce qu'on a réussi
avec l'électricité en 1945
voilà une chose qui serait nécessaire à
notre pays pour lui permettre de faire
face à un avenir la menace et ce n'est
qu'un exemple dernière question sur ce
thème est-ce que par la force des choses
le candidat michel rocard ne serait pas
tenté de faire rêver les français et par
hypothèse le président michel rocard
chargés de leur ouvrir les yeux
je ne suis pas sûr de bien comprendre ce
que vous voulez dire soir et c'est tout
lorsqu en effet l'incertitude menace
dans le monde
le temps n'est pas aux rêves
le temps est peut-être à l'enthousiaste
c'est différent il est à la lucidité
je suis persuadé j'ai tout à leur
manquer de vous reprendre sur un point
alors que tous nos voisins sont rien
dans des voies différentes
ce n'est pas vrai bien de nos voisins
scandinaves et allemands continuent à
approfondir leur expérience sociale et
comme vous le savez le son c'est fort
différente et la dumont la social
démocratie ça fait avancer mais il fait
meilleur être ouvrier en suède ou en
allemagne qu'en france
simplement c'est toujours le capitalisme
mais c'est un capitalisme mieux
contrôler ses frais il reste que le
capitalisme lui-même est en crise
mondiale son système monétaire d'abord
et nous sommes tous aux recherches
monsieur palmer vous le dirai mieux que
moi il est là dessus très fort nous
sommes tous cherchent de la vraie
solution socialiste nous on recherche
c'est plus au niveau de la recherche
intellectuelle c'est maintenant du
passage à l'application qu'il est
question il y faut un enthousiasme il
faut une volonté collective et je suis
sûr que les français préféreront cela la
politique de l'autruche car l'analyse
qui sous-tendait votre remarque de tout
à l'heure c'est qu'il vaut mieux se
mettre la tête dans le sable quand le
monde change et qu'on a craint je joue
ma crainte non mais en fait l'idée que
l'on s'abrite derrière une sécurité
quand le monde change et qu'on ne sait
plus quoi faire c'est justement la
politique de l'autruche et c'est ce que
je combattrai d'abord concrètement
helmut schmidt chancelier fédéral social
démocrate ne donne pas le sentiment de
prendre dans le domaine économique des
risques considérables ni de faire
beaucoup d'expérimentation c'est l'année
dernière à ma connaissance qu'une loi
dont on peut discuter le principe je ne
pense pas que la france suivrait le même
chemin mais qui a eu une grosse
extension de loi de cogestion donc ça va
dans le sens contraire de ce que vous
venez de manier le moment michel rocard
étoffer les accréditations ça 2 c'est un
aménagement des rapports sociaux
conforme aux traditions de l'allemagne
fédérale qui ne sont pas les nôtres
il y a en france une vieille
méfiance entre le monde patronal monde
ouvrier et de la part du monde voyait
les biens légitimes
le chiffres sont encore secrets rappelez
vous la seule la seule ordonnance sur la
participation 1967 et bien le général de
gaulle lui même n'avait pas songé que
les quelques sommes donc il voulait bien
donnez bénéfices aux travailleurs
pourraient être soumises dans l'heure
des comptes à leurs examens à travers le
comité d'entreprise ne regardez pas les
comptes toujours secrets alors quand on
en est là c'est ce qu'on appelle
exactement la lutte des classes et il
est clair que l'organisation des
relations entre employeurs et
travailleurs dans de pareilles
conditions sera plus tendu plus
conflictuel qu'elle ne l'est dans
d'autres pays je ne crois donc pas que
les tentatives qui se fondent allemagne
fédérale souhaite adapter à la france je
ne crois pas je crois qu'il faut
d'autres positions pour sortir de la
méfiance
il n'empêche que vous ne pouvez pas dire
que l'homme et ferrals de feu vert de
son côté ses avancées en ce moment est
peut-être venu
michel rocard d'abord n'avez vous tous
les aspects de politique intérieure vous
avez vu récemment que georges marchais
avait décidé de prendre la tête d'une
campagne pour la défense des droits de
l'homme est ce que vous apportez votre
signature son comité
j'aurais pu apporter ma signature si la
défense des droits de l'homme avait été
complète et s'il n'y avait pas un
certain tri je tiens que monsieur
sakharov notamment et pas mal d'autres
ont subi aussi au nom des droits de
l'homme des atteintes graves et puis là
l'information est peut-être plus
disponible sur certains pays que sur
d'autres est en fait un examen de ce qui
se passe en union soviétique serait
nécessaire comment est-ce que vous jugez
l'attitude du parti communiste en ce
moment comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer est-ce que vous ne l'aviez
prévu et au fond qu'est ce que vous vous
sentez en commun aujourd'hui avec
georges marchais
c'est beaucoup de questions en une
latitude est parti communiste français
et je le désapprouve profondément mais
elle se comprend c'est waldeck rochet
qui avait présidé au lancement de cette
longue recherche de cette ligne
politique était celle de l'union de la
gauche et d'un programme commun de
gouvernement
cela a suscité en france c'est vrai un
espoir considérable et une montée
progressive de la gauche il s'est trouvé
que dans ce renforcement commun
le parti socialiste serait fort offre
renforcée grandissait plus vite encore
que le parti communiste français
la règle de l'union c'était de
l'accepter après tout après tout les
socialistes avec les listes de signer le
programme commun alors qu'ils étaient
minoritaires dans la gauche c'est un
risque en face on ne veut pas prendre le
parti communiste français lui n'accepte
plus visiblement une union de la gauche
dans lequel il n'est pas dominant c'est
dramatique mais c'est ainsi de la même
façon il est clair il fait des analyses
de politique internationale qui l'amène
à se déclarer plutôt solidaire de
l'union soviétique que d'une autre
vision et qui l'amène par conséquent a
refusé que à travers une arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir en france soit par
exemple lancé proposé une relance de la
construction européenne autour d'une
base planifié favorable aux travailleurs
il y à une attente de ce côté là et les
propositions françaises seraient
importantes c'est tout cela que le parti
communiste français rend impossible avec
la lhjmq il a choisi je les désapprouve
profondément mais elle n'est pas ici
avec son je crois même qu'elle ne soit
choisi pour longtemps justement avec son
langage actuel ses méthodes ses mots
d'ordre est ce qu'on croit pas qu'il
croyait pas qu'il ya une sorte de
tentations néo staliniennes dans le
parti je ne dirai rien tel vous avez
terminé la question précédente en me
demandant ce qu'il restait de commun
georges marchais et nous je n'aime pas
qu'on cite les hommes ici il s'agit des
organismes de direction nos deux parties
ce qu'il ya de commun reste tout à fait
fondamental c'est que nous sommes
taillés que nous sommes ensemble les
représentants du monde du travail en
france
autrement dit ce sont les clefs diane
rasd en commun et bien sûr les électeurs
le monde du travail
c'est pas seulement une affaire
d'élection c'est aussi une affaire de
bataille quotidienne y compris
parlementaire d'ailleurs pour une
fiscalité moins injuste pour une
sécurité sociale plus complète pour etc
dans toutes ces batailles la gauche et
solidaire et et on le sait bien il se
voit de manière constante mais pas au
niveau des dirigeants les appareils la
ligne qu'a choisi le parti communiste
français que j'expliquais tout à l'heure
le rend impossible et je suis de ceux
qui préfèrent tirer le constat sans
passer du temps à réfléchir davantage
une illusion de dissocier les électeurs
communistes de leurs dirigeants c'est
d'autant moins une illusion que c'est ça
qui fait les chances de la gauche à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
car enfin qu'est ce qui va se passer
à paris ce n'est pas à paris c'est le
résultat de situation qu'elle soit sur
des choses sérieuses de cette nature
s'il vous plaît au départ nous le dise
la rue il y à un une proposition une
volonté socialiste proposait à la france
nous avons très loyalement pendant la
période du programme commun tenter le
compromis au niveau programmatique au
niveau de l'intention avec nos
partenaires communistes cela s'avère
impossible ils n'en veulent plus voilà
qui est clair
résultats qui en découlent c'est au
niveau de la volonté politique proposée
aux français la gauche en aura deux là
socialistes et les communistes et les
français choisiront
et qu'est ce qui va se passer au
deuxième tour les électeurs communistes
et et au delà même de la sensibilité des
lecteurs le les syndicalistes cgt le
monde du travail qui se sent en
communication avec le parti communiste
va se trouver dans la situation suivante
est ce qu'on reconduit giscard d'estaing
ou est ce qu'on choisit un projet de
changement social qui n'est pas le
projet communiste certes qui en est
différent sur bien des points
quels autres mais qui est tout de même
un projet de diminuer les injustices
sociales en france 2 diffusé mieux la
responsabilité de l'autorité
collectivités locales entreprises
nous y étions tout à l'heure voilà le
choix et je ne suis par mois du tout
persuadé que la majorité de l'électorat
communiste souhaite le maintien au
pouvoir de l'actuel président des agoras
ses dirigeants alors concrètement ce
n'est pas du tout impossible qu'on que
sommes en démocratie ils sont pas
prisonniers des consignes du bureau
politique
concrètement continuons dans votre
hypothèse c'est à dire que le candidat
socialiste est qualifié pour le second
tour en étant devant le candidat
communiste et par hypothèse toujours il
est élu bombe à ce moment là il faut que
ces débats de l'intéressante alors
justement on va essayer la préciser ça
signifie que dans ce cas là il faut
qu'il a un gouvernement pour gouverner
et une majorité au parlement
alors votre gouvernement par hypothèse
toujours où le fait avec qui avec ou
sans les communistes et votre majorité
au parlement vous la trouvez ou majorité
au parlement puis je vous rappeler un
modeste détail de 1958 à 1962
général de gaulle n'en a pas eu général
de gaulle c'était le général de gaulle
il a su donner à la france
oui mais il commençait à 0 des
institutions qui permettent justement si
c'est compte tenu de l'éclatement du
pays et de son partage dans de
nombreuses forces parce qu'après tout je
crie non seulement j'accepte mais
j'assume tout à fait que vous me posiez
cette question parce que ce n'est pas
beaucoup plus simple à droite sous
giscard d'estaing dans mêmes tracas avec
les forces du rpr et on ne voit pas là
une très grande stabilité m'enfin c'est
leur affaire ils sont des brouillons
toujours est il que la france fait ses
grands choix en donnant accord aux
options proposées par un candidat à la
présidence de la république et que la
logique de nos institutions c'est que le
pays s'organisent autour de ces options
que par conséquent du gouvernement le
gouvernement sera composé des courants
des hommes et des femmes qui se sont
reconnus dans ses options c'est-à-dire
le social il est radicaux de gauche peut
être écologiste peut-être venue du p du
parti socialiste unifié tous ceux qui se
seront reconnus le parti dans les lycées
si le compagnon de route
je ne vois pas vous avez voulu
travailler
je voudrais pour ma part dire que si par
exemple certains représentants du
mouvement écologiste ou les radicaux de
gauche se reconnaissent dans ses options
qui ne seront pas négocier ainsi d'abord
je ne crois pas au compromis bâtard et
boiteux il faut qu'elles soient claires
il faut qu'elle soit à discuter mais
elles seront voulue ouverte et que ce
soit françois mitterrand ou moi même je
suis sûr de cette volonté que les
options soit de rassemblement je
n'aimerais pas traiter deux compagnons
de route les hommes qui se reconnaîtront
dans ses options commune car ils ont un
droit évident à préserver leur identité
politique et leur volonté leur existence
et nous le préserveront voilà pourquoi
j'ai tiqué sur cette expression
vous l'avez voulu descriptif et je vous
en donne acte mais mais il me fallait
corriger on avait la volonté actuelle du
parti communiste en tout cas fait que
lui ne paraît pas être candidat nous en
prenons acte
parfait de toute façon
parti communiste pourrait changer d'avis
je vous disais tout à l'heure que je
n'en crois rien n'aurait examinerions
parce qu'il est vrai aussi que
participer au gouvernement ça se mérite
et que aujourd'hui en ce moment il ne le
veut pas l'évidence
enfin demandez lui il voulut lui avait
fait dire d'ailleurs je ne suis pas là
son porte parole mais vous voyez votre
tentation votre idée c'est de les faire
participer au gouvernement d'avoir des
ministres communistes dans un
gouvernement dans le gouvernement
la prodige unis celle ci vous étiez
naturellement l'effort de l'union de la
gauche depuis plus de dix ans était
justement l'effort de faire rentrer en
démocratie tout le monde communiste
français ces électeurs ses militants
sont partis
voilà l'effort auquel je ne renoncerai
pas il est clair que nous menons cet
effort sans accepter le moindre
compromis notamment sur les droits de
l'homme ni sur l'indépendance nationale
de quelques côtés qu'on juge qu'elle est
tirée aujourd'hui c'est par rapport à
l'union soviétique que nous nous
interrogeons sur l'indépendant le
rapport avec l'indépendance nationale
française du parti communiste français
c'est clair mais il n'en reste pas moins
qu'un électeur communiste est un
habitant de ce pays français comme nous
qui a la même histoire les mêmes
traditions qui a probablement s'il est
un peu hein j'ai vécu la phase de la
résistance avec une grande intensité qui
est lié au monde du travail et qui a sa
place dans le jeu démocratique des
institutions de notre pays ça n'est pas
nous qui leur fermerons la porte qui se
ferme tout seul
simplement que nous ne sommes pas dur
d'oreille nous avons compris et nous ne
devrons pas cette porte refermée par les
aveux de la rouvrir ce qui signifie
concrètement que toujours par hypothèse
si vous étiez lui ce serait un
gouvernement socialiste avec des
écologies de majoritaire les manches
comme de gaulle au début ces frais
homogène comprendre un mot qu'on est en
plein en ce moment avec vous radicaux de
gauche evo écologistes
oui on peut le dire ainsi je voudrais
que le mode homogène vous l'employez
soit bien compris comme pas limiter ou
seule foncière du bâti socialisme alors
à ce moment vous avez toujours par
hypothèse votre gouvernement et votre
majorité maintenant au parlement et bien
peut-être vais-je vous surprendre vous
souvenez vous que les grandes lois
sociales du front populaire
après une bataille électorale très
difficile très haineuse très insultant
on était une centaine d'invités ont été
votés à l'unanimité vous le savez qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
quand la représentation populaire d'un
pays se voient proposer une grande
ambition de grands projets des réformes
importantes ressenti que nécessaire
elle passe et on peut en tout cas faire
un tri et je gage pour ma part qu'un
président de la république française
socialiste aurait naturellement avant de
dissoudre la chambre dans les quelques
semaines où les quelques mois la volonté
et la capacité de fournir de faire
fournir par son gouvernement tout la
traduction législative de ses intentions
et c'est sur la base de ces projets
qu'on verra bien qui choisit qui la
logique de nos institutions n'est pas
que l'étroitesse et les rigidités du
système de parti contraignent et limite
la présidence
la logique de nos institutions et que
l'ampleur des choix faits à partir de la
présidence modèle tout le système est
d'une certaine façon on peut regretter
qu'en six ans maintenant demande à
monsieur giscard d'estaing n'ait pas
pris plus options pour éviter que la
france ne retombe lorsque lui-même
appelle le régime des partis on n'a pas
bien senti les réformes
la volonté présidentielle du
gouvernement à vau-l'eau les seules
réformes passées sont celles qui
touchent notre vie privée rien
d'essentiel n'a changé dans
l'organisation sociale de notre pays et
rien non plus n'a changé dans la
pression que la présidence de la
république exerce sur notre système de
parti c'est tout de même un camp mais
concrètement si peur
hypothèse le rpr et l'udf et le pc
n'était pas brusquement séduit par ses
propositions
autrement dit si la situation se
trouvait comme elle est aujourd'hui à
savoir moins d'un député socialiste ou
radical de gauche sur quatre à
l'assemblée nationale bon il faut quand
même bien de majorité pour gouverner et
combien de temps qu'est ce qui se passe
je ne fais pas ça égouttez de deux
choses l'une
quand une expérience nouvelle 1 se
déroule choisi par le suffrage universel
il ya en effet au début un temps de
grâce il faut faire des choses
importantes et vite
nous y sommes prêts et nous savons
lesquelles et puis l'on de l'éco aime ou
pas elles réussissent ou elle échoue ce
n'est pas la peine de tourner autour du
pot la question vous venez de me poser
est celle de l'échec
bon un peu plus tôt un peu plus tard je
parie mois sur la réussite la france
attend depuis si longtemps à la fois une
réforme fiscale correct une modification
des pouvoirs de ces communes une réforme
régionale importante
une autre politique étrangère une lutte
contre les inégalités qui taraude
toujours ce pays une réforme des modes
de financement notre sécurité sociale je
l'oubliais c'est peut-être le plus
urgent tout ceci est aussi une
démocratisation notre sécurité sociale
qui était une conquête des travailleurs
dont les élus organisé et faisait
marcher le système et qui est maintenant
une immense bureaucratie tout ceci peut
citer d'immenses un peu de sympathie
ouvrir les frontières et permettre que
les législatives suivantes se fasse sur
d'autres bases élargi après tout la
france est un des pays d'europe où le
socialisme démocratique n'a pas trouvé
la place normal qu'il a partout l'europe
et développer nous sommes dans cette
période de rattrapage
l'élection d'un socialiste à la
présidence accélérer la rapidité du
rattrapage
mais naturellement c'est bien la partie
que nous engageons mais si par hypothèse
c'était un communiste qui était en tête
est-ce que vous iriez pêcher à la ligne
comme monsieur pisani ou est ce que vous
feriez des discours sur les estrades
entre les deux tours pour l'aider à être
élu si c'était un communiste qui était
en tête de la gauche au premier tour
tous les espoirs qui animent notre lutte
depuis
10 15 ans sinon davantage s'effondrerait
georges marchais lui-même a dit j'ai le
document là je vais citer la phrase de
mémoire dans le rapport secret mais qui
fut publié trois ans après 1974 qu'à son
avis l'état d'esprit des français
n'étaient pas mûrs pour permettre
l'élection d'un communiste la présidence
de la république française
il aurait fait tout pour ça je doute il
fait en plus tout pour ça je doute que
sur ce point décisif et les changer
d'avis comme la phrase est de lui
j'en conclu qu'en effet l'hypothèse d'un
candidat communiste en tête de la gauche
au premier tour et l'hypothèse de la
défaite au second nous espoirs seront en
berne
il nous faudra à ce moment là je ne
crois pas du tout le moins du monde de
cette hypothèse d'ailleurs pas ce qui se
passera mais j'ai la loyauté de répondre
à vos questions après tout reprendre le
travail
continuer à convaincre les travailleurs
de ce pays que la ligne politique du
parti communiste français la plus
sécurisante pour monsieur giscard
d'estaing pour le maintien de la droite
au pouvoir
il reste que la particule élémentaire
l'élément le plus un film le plus
fondamental de l'union de la gauche
celui autour duquel le rassemblement
avait commencé
c'est la discipline républicaine elle
est d'ailleurs une tradition bien plus
ancienne que la naissance même du parti
socialiste et du parti communiste et
cela ne sera pas remise en cause ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs ce que je vais vous
le dire mon ami pisani dont je m'honore
de l'amitié on pensa qu'il avait fait
allusion pour suivre le raisonnement
dans cette hypothèse de l'échec de la
gauche c'est à dire de la réélection de
valéry giscard d'estaing la présidence
de la république s'il faisait une
nouvelle tentative d'ouverture en
direction de ceux qui n'ont pas été dans
sa majorité
est-ce que vous accepteriez ce que
pensent beaucoup de gens vous pourriez
de son premier ministre
écoutez je n'aime pas beaucoup la
politique spectacle et tout ces fadaises
curieuse j'ai du mal à les comprendre
enfin d'abord si une fois de plus hélas
la gauche se trouvaient encore battu se
montrerait que la droite se suffit-elle
et qu'elle n'a besoin de personne pour
gouverner de quel droit bientôt en plus
nous demander verra-t-on nous demander
d'aller combler je ne sais quel trou
dans le dispositif
c'est tout de même pas de notre faute à
nous aussi il a du mal à faire monter du
personnel politique de talent nous ne
sommes pas là pour faire ce travail là
si vous permettez la défense des
intérêts des travailleurs exigent
d'autres combats mais en plus pourquoi
ce genre d'hypothèse
alors que la gauche n'a jamais défaillir
quand il s'agit de voter de bonne
réforme va on était là pour la
contraception et pour l'interruption de
grossesse nous avons été là où
l'abaissement de l'âge de la majorité
électorale
nous avons été là pour la facilitation
des procédures de divorce la gauche fait
central
il ya un parlement en bourse cela nous
pourrions nous rencontrer sur des
quantités de réformes positives pour la
france qu'elle vienne on discutera ce
sera bien intéressant et à partir du
moment où le corps législatif seraient
amenés à sanctionner des décisions qui
vont dans l'intérêt général et qui ont
une grande approbation le jeu sans doute
serait changée en politique politicienne
mais si vous voulez bien
inutile d'évoquer de pareille hypothèse
avant alors monsieur rocard venons en
maintenant à des problèmes plus
prosaïque est relativement plus immédiat
c'est à dire la désignation du candidat
socialiste pour les élections
présidentielles aujourd'hui vous avez
dit tout à l'heure vous même d'ailleurs
vous avez raison que c'est qu'il ya deux
candidats qui sont possibles qui sont
françois mitterrand et vous même alors
qu'est ce qui politiquement ou
économiquement vous sépare de françois
mitterrand sinon le fait que vous êtes 2
qui peut y avoir qu'un seul candidat
je dirais d'abord qu'à mon sens le parti
socialiste était fort sage
de décider que sa décision sur ce
problème interviendrait à l'automne
quel que soit le ton et la nature de
notre conversation de ce soir je ne
crois pas bon que la france souhaite en
campagne électorale permanente une
campagne électorale c'est le temps fort
d'une démocratie c'est intense pour
l'élection présidentielle les français
sont appelés à réfléchir à quantité de
dossiers quantité de problèmes pour tous
gpt est beaucoup difficile
il est bon que cela soit limité dans le
temps
cela ne rendra que plus d'importance et
leur réflexion je crois que nous avons
été sages et par conséquent mais ont
sûrement pas jusqu'au bout du propos
puisque la décision ne sera prise à
l'automne et que c'est l'ensemble des
adhérents du parti socialiste qui
ratifiera le choix les cela est demandé
nous avons eu françois mitterrand et
moi-même nous sommes je lis beaucoup la
presse et et j apprends que j'aurai avec
lui de très mauvais rapports excusez moi
nous sommes des socialistes responsables
et je veux dire d'abord l'estiment que
je porte au travail historique qu'il a
fait la tentation de sortir le
particulier la tentative de sortir le
parti communiste français de son ghetto
et la reconstruction du parti socialiste
et son rassemble nous avons eu c'est
vrai des différends politiques
il me semble qu'on si bien la situation
internationale que la situation de
politique intérieure actuelle et la
ligne suivie par le parti communiste
français réduisent l'ampleur de ces
différends politiques
c'est important et économique nous avons
eu aussi des différends économiques et
cela nous n'avons pas reparlé il n'y a
pas eu d'actualisation net je parle je
n'évoque pas ici le document la fresque
à 15h du projet socialiste il faut que
les mesures pour tout de suite
une fresque à 15 ans est une chose c'est
une engagement de propositions
structurelles très longue
lorsqu'on s'engage pour gouverner c'est
sur le court terme il est sûr que nous
avions hérité de la période d'expansion
forte qui a duré jusque vers 19h la fin
72 début 73
un espoir de profiter de la rapidité de
la croissance pour remodeler vite la
distribution des revenus en france et
faire vite grâce à la croissance et des
pareils des réformes de structure
fondamentale et il est vrai que nous
avons ensuite divergé ait eu des
désaccords entre nous sur la mesure des
possibilités que nous laissait amoindri
le ralentissement de cette croissance
mais maintenant que les choses
deviennent plus évidente
maintenant que le prix du pétrole dans
sa hausse continue entraîne un
ralentissement spontanée regrettable
d'ailleurs de cette croissance est
d'autant plus fort que le gouvernement
corrige mal à mon avis nous ne faisons
pas de planification pour corriger nos
notre lancée notre organisation
économique je ne pense pas que sur un
programme à court terme nous direz
lanceur est grave mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a une coloration si vous voulez et que
sans doute françois mitterrand
représente une volonté socialiste qui
fait très fortement confiance à
l'appareil public à l'appareil de l'état
à l'administration pour transformer la
société
alors je suis peut être un peu davantage
porteur d'une volonté socialiste plus
appuyé sur la méfiance devant la
bureaucratie sur la volonté d'une
décentralisation d'une plus forte
responsabilité des collectivités locales
des travailleurs l'entreprise et d'une
limitation de l'administration d'état à
ce qui doit être sa seule charge
vous doutiez de 1977 tout à fait mais
vous savez que ces deux traditions sont
très anciennes en mouvement socialiste
français que celle que je représente est
peut-être la plus ancienne des deux vous
ment socialiste est né de bourse de
travail de coopératives et mutuelles et
ses trente ans après qui s'est façonné
autour d'une vision dans laquelle
l'appareil de l'état occuper la place
centrale
concrètement il y aura deux candidats
possibles mais de françois mitterrand
les vous et ce sont les militants du
parti socialiste qui voteront pour
savoir fait les meilleurs je n'en suis
pas sûr et je ne vous cacherai pas que
je souhaite éviter cette situation
le parti socialiste est relativement
jeune c'est un rassemblement récent à
tous les confluents on voit encore 500
ou 800 m 1 km après le confluent les os
mais les doucement et décoloration
différentes
les colorations historique des hommes
rassemblés dans le parti socialiste ne
sont pas encore bien mélanger nous ne
sommes pas habitués au à la démocratie
au point de prendre le risque d'une
bataille interne frontale qui nous
laisserait pas le temps des
réconciliations pour que la campagne
soit mené pour le pineau le parti n'est
pas en état de divisions déjà les parts
conséquentes d'affaiblissement
le parti est en état d'hésitation mais
je ne doute pas un instant que françois
mitterrand est comme moi même un grand
sens de ses responsabilités un grand
souci de l'unité du parti
je ne doute donc pas qu'il y aura un
candidat de consensus un candidat
d'agrément dans d'accord dans notre
parti et je fais donc le pronostic que
ça se passera plus tôt mais il semblait
y croire c'est à dire ils ont
concrètement voulu premier les faits
semblables que les militants socialistes
auront à ratifier une seule candidature
c'est possible concrètement vous proposé
à françois mitterrand la présidence du
comité de soutien
zéro car de même que probablement il me
proposerait dans l'hypothèse inverse est
la sienne ma foi mais nous regardons les
modalités plus tard si vous voulez bien
encore une fois ne m'intéresse pas
et est ce que vous croyez que le
candidat socialiste veut être le
candidat d'un parti je voulais dit tout
à l'heure
notre système de parti a beaucoup
d'importance en france il est
relativement rigide mais il marque et
par conséquent le candidat proposé par
un parti se trouve avoir des chances une
installation de dans la situation
politique meilleur que s'il ne l'est pas
mais je pense aussi qu'il est du devoir
notamment pour le candidat du parti
socialiste de bien d'obtenir l'accord de
son parti sur le fait qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'une candidature étroitement liée à
un mandat impératif de partis qu'il
s'agit au contraire de rassembler des
forces innombrables qui se cherche
il y au fond dans ce pays d'une part une
gauche classique qui seule une gauche
très ancienne
une longue histoire et de long combat
derrière elle qui se reconnaît qui se
connaît qui se mesure et puis de
nombreux coureurs je pense notamment aux
écologistes mais il y en a dans la
tanche centrale de lectorat du pays il y
en a aussi sur son extrême gauche qui ne
savent pas très bien où se situer qui
voudrait que beaucoup de choses changent
et en même temps garder un procès d des
grands partis traditionnels dont le bien
c'est ces hommes-là six femmes là qu'il
faut convaincre à mener au combat
politique et je pense ce sera le rôle
d'un candidat proposé par le parti
socialiste je tiens beaucoup à cette
forme et j'ai tord et pour obtenir ce
consensus à ce que la meilleure façon
c'est cette façon de presser sur le
parti de l'extérieur par les sondages
par différentes interventions peut-être
cartes sur table ou vous répondez à nos
amis de se lancer
oui mais jamais je du pôle les moyens je
donne pas les moyens d'ailleurs je n'ai
jamais commandé un seul sondage je lis
avec le même intérêt que vous peut être
un peu moins d'ailleurs que je suis dans
nos salles et prend de manière évolutive
ou font pas tellement de peine quand
même non mais
il vaudra mieux ne pour appuyer une
stratégie politique exclusivement sur
eux croyez moi c'est une prudence est en
tout cas je me regarde bien l an michel
rocard en qu est ce que vous seriez un
meilleur candidat pour le parti
socialiste que françois mitterrand
sauf si vous permettez c'est une des
questions que nous enverrons à l'automne
je n'aurai ni l'outrecuidance de mauvais
goût de répondre à une question à ses
formes mais qu il apposera et de quelle
façon
encore une fois si c'est pas nous les
principaux responsables du parti
socialiste auront-elles d entre eux en
consultant beaucoup en consultant leurs
élus et ma foi
le problème est celui du candidat le
plus efficace pour rire se rassembler
pour ça que vous posez la question je ne
suis pas en état de vous dire maintenant
comment les réflexions les pensées le
sens de leur responsabilité des
principaux élus responsables dirigeants
du parti socialiste aboutir à une
candidature de consensus nous en
reparlerons les airs de ce processus
peut conduire effectivement affaires de
michel brault cas le candidat le plus
efficace c'est possible ce n'est pas
certain parce que vous vous en sentez
capable je l'espère par conséquent on ne
vous pose pas de questions sur votre
candidature l'élection présidentielle il
nous semble compté pour être franc que
depuis une heure vous avez pratiquement
commencé votre campagne présidentielle
c'est d'autres autos merci regretté je
n'ai pas dit cela
[Musique]